GREG: TONIGHT THE ELECTION
AFTERMATH, CONSERVATIVES
EXPRESSED THEIR RAGE ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY.
HERE'S TAPE OF THE CHAOS IN THE
STREETS.
IT DID NOT END THERE.
MALLS AND SHOPPING CENTERS
BECAME TARGETS OF OUR WRATH.
UGLY, UGLY, UGLY.
WE DID NOT STOP THERE BUT HIT
THE STREETS TO TALK TO THE
TRAUMATIZED.
>> FOX NEWS DECISION SAYS THE
DEMOCRATS WILL TAKE CONTROL OF
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN EIGHT YEARS.
~ MEDUSA BACK TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S LEGISLATION ADDENDA.
>> [BLEEP] ARE YOU THAT UPSET
ABOUT THE MIDTERMS?
>> NO MAN.
WE HAVE TO HIT THE BATTING
CAGES.
>> OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
>> DEMOCRATS CONTROL THE HOUSE.
THE REASON WE MAKE THE CALL
IS -- [INAUDIBLE]
>> DID YOU HEAR ABOUT THE
MIDTERMS?
>> NO.
BUT I HIT 50 IN A ROW.
>> AWESOME JOB, BRO.
>> IT'S A VERY, VERY BIG DEAL.
>> I WANT TO DIE.
MY HAIR, BLACK OR BROWN.
NOTHING NEW.
>> GIVING PRESSURE UP TO
LIBERALS WHO WANT TO INVESTIGATE
BOX --
>> WE LOST THE HOUSE.
>> NO, WE DIDN'T.
IT'S RIGHT THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: THERE YOU GO?
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
AS YOU CAN SEE, WE DID NOT HIT
THE STREETS.
WE DID NOT HIT ANYTHING.
WHAT A COMPARISON TO 2016.
TWO YEARS AGO WHEN THE
REPUBLICANS HELD THE HOUSE AND
THERE WAS THIS.
GREG: NOW ON WEDNESDAY WHEN WE
LOSE THERE IS THIS.
♪.
GREG: SO TRUE.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
BUT GET THIS.
THERE WERE PROTESTS BUT NOT FROM
THE LOSING SIDE OF THE ACTUAL
WINNERS.
MAKING THEM THE WORLD'S BIGGEST
LOSERS AT WINNING.
THIS PROTEST TOOK PLACE ON
THURSDAY AND THEY WERE HOWLING
OVER TRUMP FIRING JEFF SESSIONS.
HE WAS ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR 636
DAYS AND ENTRANCE WHITE HOUSE
THAT IS A LONG TIME.
IT IS 63.5 ANTHONY SCARY MOVIES.
[LAUGHTER]
SO HOW DESPERATE AND LONELY DOES
THE LIBERAL HAVE TO BE TO
PROTEST THE FIRING OF A RIGHT
WINGER?
THEY ARE SAD THAT SESSIONS IS
GONE BUT HE'S TO THE RIGHT OF
GENGHIS KHAN.
HE WOULD GIVE YOU THE ELECTRIC
CHAIR FOR WEARING SANDALS TO
WORK.
I'M PRETTY SURE HE HUNTS BEGINS
ON A PRIVATE ISLAND.
NUDE BEGINS.
[LAUGHTER]
I DON'T KNOW WHY I ADDED THAT.
IF THAT IS WHAT LEFTISTS DO WHEN
THEY WIN WHAT WOULD THEY HAVE
DONE IF THEY HAD LOST?
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: I REALLY FEEL BAD FOR
SHARE.
[LAUGHTER]
SHE JUST HAS A NEW TEAR DUCTS.
IT'S A LESSON ABOUT LOSING AND
WINNING AND ITS THEY CAN'T STAND
TO WIN AND THAT WOULD MEAN THEY
CANNOT WHINE.
HERE'S THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BEING TOLD HE'S
ONE HOUSE BUT NOT THE SENATE.
♪.
GREG: GIVE THEM THE HOUSE AND
THE STORM YOURS.
YOU EXTEND A HAND IN THEY GIVE
YOU THE FINGER.
FOR US IT'S ANOTHER DAY AND WE
HAVE LIFE.
WHEN I FIRST HEARD THE DEMOCRATS
ONE, IT HURT.
I HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO DO THIS.
>> I'M MAKING A PEANUT BUTTER
AND JELLY SANDWICH.
B5 WHAT CAN I DO?
I LIKE PEANUT BUTTER AND JELLY.
EVEN WHEN WE LOSE, WE KNOW WE
WILL WHEN THE NEXT TIME WE SEE
THE BRIGHT SIDE EVERYWHERE.
WITH THE HOUSE DURING BLUE
DONALD TRUMP REALLY HAS A NEW
FRIEND, A NEW FOIL AND IT'S LIKE
WHEN THE JEFFERSONS WITH NEXT
DOOR TO ARCHIE BUNKER.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T REMEMBER
THAT BUT ISN'T IT MORE FUN TO
PLAY TENNIS AGAINST ANOTHER
PERSON AND NOT A GARAGE DOOR
EVEN IF THAT PERSON IS NANCY
PELOSI?
ALL RIGHT.
MAYBE NOT.
MORE GOOD NEWS.
THREE LEADERS OF THE CABIN OUT
WHICH TRIAL GOT BOOTED.
THAT'S A GREAT MESSAGE.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
THE MESSAGE PUT FAIRNESS BEHIND
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS TO SUSPEND
DUE PROCESS AND YOU'RE OUT ON
YOUR COWARDLY ASS.
I HOPE THERE NEXT JOB IS SERVING
BEER.
I LOVE BEER.
FINALLY, THE OTHER SILVER
LINING, MOST BELOVED PROGRESSIVE
OF ALL LOST.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
THE MEDIA CALLED THIS KENNEDY
ASKED AND THEY WERE NOT
REFERRING TO HIS DRIVING.
[LAUGHTER]
HE WAS IRAQ STAR WITHOUT THE
HERPES.
I'M GLAD HE LOST IT ONLY TO
DRIVE HIS CELEBRITY FANS WHO
NEVER HEARD OF HIM UNTIL A FEW
MONTHS AGO NOT SEE THIS
MYSTERIOUS SPACE OBJECT.
YOU MIGHT BELIEVE IS AN ALIEN
SPACECRAFT BUT THAT IS FATAL
LEAVING FOR HIS HOME PLANET.
[LAUGHTER]
THE ETO WHEN YOU SEE THE HYPE
KNOW THERE'S LESS THAN MEETS THE
EYE WITH IMMEDIATE LIBERTIES
DURING TOGETHER OVER A CANDIDATE
YOU KNOW HE OR SHE WILL BE TO
THE LEFT OF ANYONE WITH A PULSE.
OR MADONNA.
[LAUGHTER]
COMPARE THAT TO -- INSULT
MADONNA AND YOU ARE LIKE -- GEEZ
LOUISE.
COMPARE THAT TO DROP AND GET THE
MOST MEDIA ATTENTION OF ANYONE
AND IT WAS FREE BUT MOSTLY
NEGATIVE WHICH PROVES IF THE
MEDIA TELLS YOU ONE THING YOU'LL
ALWAYS DO THE OTHER.
NO ONE HYPED TRUMP AS THE NEXT
GREAT THING.
THE MEDIA TURNED CIRCUS
PROMOTERS AND WALL-TO-WALL CLOWN
HIM AND THAT CLOWN WIPED THE
FLOOR WITH HILLARY'S E-MAILS.
MAYBE THERE A LESSON HERE FOR
DEMOCRATS?
BETO BECAUSE ALL OF HIS FAULTS
HE WAS REAL.
THE DEMOCRATS CROP OF CANDIDATES
FOR 2020 AREN'T.
THEY ARE POOL TOYS WORTHLESS AND
WAITING TO BE INFLATED.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT MAYBE THEY WILL FIGURE IT
OUT.
MY SUGGESTION, GO PRETTY
EXCITING VOICES OF YOUR PARTY.
♪.
GREG: OR MAYBE THIS ♪
GREG: OR PERHAPS THIS.
♪.
GREG: HAMSTER AS A BP?
WHY NOT.
WE ALMOST HAD TIM CAME.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S CHAMP,
HE SO SHARP HE CAN POKE HOLES IN
WATER, TV WRITER AND PRODUCER
ROB LONG.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
FIRST, FIRST-TIME GUEST HE'S A
PEDIATRIC HE WANTS DATED THE
STATUE OF LIBERTY, AND AUTHOR
AND FORMER SECRET SERVICE AGENT,
DAN LONGINO.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SHE IS SO BRIGHT YOU CAN SEE HER
THOUGHTS FROM SPACE, NATIONAL
SECURITY ANALYST MORGAN ORTEGA'
ORTEGA'S.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
AND UNLIKE THE DEMOCRATS HE
COULD LITERALLY FLIP A HOUSE.
FORMER YOU WWE SUPERSTAR AND MY
MASSIVE SIDEKICK, TYRUS.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
ALL RIGHT, ROB.
GIVE YOUR TAKE ON THIS WEEK ON
THE OUTCOME.
>> OUTCOME WAS WHAT WE EXPECTED.
THE RED STATES WERE VOTED RED
AND THE DEMOCRATS TURNED THE
HOUSE BUT LOOK, CLINTON, BUSH,
OBAMA AND NOW TRUMP HAVE ALL HAD
THIS HAPPEN.
EVERYONE ACTS LIKE THIS BIG
FREAKY THING BUT IT'S THE WAY IT
HAS BEEN FOR 30 YEARS.
THEY SAY IT'S A HISTORIC NOTE ON
TONIGHT AND CUT TO HIM PEOPLE
HE.
THIS IS NOTHING NEW.
I'VE SEEN THIS MOVIE AND KNOW
HOW THIS MOVIE ENDS.
IT ENDS IN TEARS.
GREG: IT DOES.
ANY OF THE CLOSE HE IS LIKE BOB
EWING, SHE'S IN THE SHOWER AND
WAS A STREAM BUT SHE'S BACK.
[LAUGHTER]
OH STOP IT.
BOBBY EWING IS FROM DALLAS.
TYRUS: I WATCH IT NEGATIVELY.
I GET IT.
HE WAS THE MORE ATTRACTIVE.
GREG: HE WAS THE ONLY ONE WHO
DIED AND THEN BROUGHT IT BACK.
GETTING OFF TRACK.
DEMOCRATS, ARE THEY THE WORST
LOSERS IN THE WORST WINNERS IN
HISTORY?
>> IT WAS HORRIBLE BECAUSE THE
SPLIT DECISION WAS GREAT FOR
TALKING HEADS LIKE GREAT FOR
BUSINESS.
THE REALITY IS IT'S HORRIBLE FOR
AMERICA BECAUSE THERE IS NO
CLEAR FRONT RUNNER FOR 2020 THE
MERGE SO HAVE TO DEAL WITH THIS
NONSENSE OF THE FACT THAT NOBODY
KICKED THE OTHER PARTIES ASS AND
NOW EVERY ONE OF THE SITES HAS
TO MAKE THE CASE OF THE NEXT TWO
YEARS IT WILL BE NO, WE WANT
BECAUSE YOU WANT THE SENATE AND
THE GOVERNOR AND NOW WE ONE AND
IT'S ALMOST LIKE A DEFINITIVE
OUTCOME JUST TO SHUT UP.
BUT IT'S GREAT FOR BUSINESS.
GREG: AMBIGUITY IS AWESOME
BECAUSE WE CAN SIT HERE AND
SCREAM ABOUT IT FOREVER.
MORGAN, WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF IT?
>> I'M JUST HAPPY FLORIDA
SCREWED UP AGAIN.
WHERE WOULD WE BE IF WE COULD
DEAL WITH THIS?
GREG: IS THE CRAZY COUSIN THAT
SHOWS UP AT THINGS GIVING AND
DECIDES TO WRITE THE LAWNMOWER
INTO THE LAKE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I'M FROM FLORIDA AND I WROTE
A THREE WHEELER INTO THE LAKE
AND MAYBE THIS MAKE SENSE.
GREG: SO YOU UNDERSTAND.
YOU ARE THE FLORIDA WHISPER.
[LAUGHTER]
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS BUT IT SOUNDS GREAT.
>> IT IS ONLY THOSE COUNTIES
THOUGH.
GREG: IT IS JUST TO COUNTIES.
TYRUS, THOUGHTS?
TYRUS: EVERYONE GOT WHAT THEY
WANTED.
EVERYONE IS STILL UPSET.
SO, WERE JUST A BUNCH OF SPOILED
KIDS.
GREG: WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THE
MIDTERM OUTCOME?
TYRUS: I JUST SAID THAT.
EVERYONE GOT WHAT THEY WANTED
AND THEY STILL COMPLAIN.
I CAN'T DEAL WITH YOU.
GREG: THEY ARE LIKE KIDS THEY
GOT WHAT THEY WANTED FOR
CHRISTMAS BUT IN THE WRONG COLO
COLOR.
>> YEAH, AND NOTICE THE
DEMOCRATS WERE MAD THAT TRUMP
SEEM TO BE CELEBRATING.
THEY WERE MAD HE WAS HAPPY.
CANNOT TO BE HAPPY AND GREAT
FREUDIAN ANALYST WOULD SAY THIS
IS EXACTLY WHAT THE PROBLEM WITH
HAPPINESS IS.
CAN'T BE HAPPY IF SOMEONE ELSE
IS HAPPY TO WHY CAN'T THEY ALL
CELEBRATE.
TYRUS: IT'S MIND GAMES.
HE COMES OUT AND SAYS GOOD JOB,
GUYS.
AND THEY LIKE KNOW YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO CRY.
HE DARTH BAYNARD THEM.